tu crois qu'ils vont me reconnaître une
les partis dits moi pas dix ans non on
reconnaît plus son frère c'est quoi ce
nouveau look là je suis un nouvel homme
dieu le miséricordieux à éclairer ma
voiture descendante et justin haythe du
moyen-âge sait que c'est parti très vite
soit noté fabrice fabrice c'est fini
maintenant c'est farid battant les
surmonter c'est quoi votre condition
guider les gens
[Musique]
avec douceur et sagesse
c'était une telle est la main du tout
manuel il s'offre à l'enfermer vraiment
mon portable
je sais pas quoi faire théo grand cas de
la gélatine de porc dans les buts un
appétit c'était fou
t'inquiète je vais te coach est hors de
question celemony koussa idem pour toi
ah non ça c'est pas une dame ça c'est
une tente quechua
quand vous appelez-vous massot shareaza
c'est moi
tu joues le jeu pendant une semaine tu
crois que ça va marcher il faut alors à
la commande elle sait ce qu'elle veut si
ce qu elle présente pas du tout avec la
religion il n'ya même pas comme les
autres tu pense constamment ce film
j'aime cette fille admission a pas
envoyé au yémen là bas pour faire le
touriste bronzer sur la plage et des
pectoraux pour havlat
je veux savoir où elle habite 30a
question tout ce qui bouge merci fabrice
hockey gervinho
oui
[Musique]
monter dans un bus comme si le bien des
deux femmes le sert à l'âme je peux pas
mais fabrice s et farid hockey fabrice
paris
ses réserves ont parlé n'entre pas les
bavolets tu fais sûrement une fixation
sur elle parce que ça fait des mois que
tu es frustré sexuellement mais ça va
aller comme
shérazade c'est décidé tu seras ma femme
[Musique]